so we're continuing to cover what
is the sort of emerging Republican
civil war between trumpets and non trumpets?
Actually, it's really Trump cultists and non
called this because many of the people who are
not part of the cult did vote Trump, but they
recognize that, like, for example, Trump lost and
it's time to move on. So it's really the cultists
versus the non cultists. And it's been titillating
and tantalizing to watch this list of Trump
enemies grow and grow and grow. And the list
of Trump enemies, depending on who you ask
now, includes Fox News, Georgia Republican
Governor Brian Kemp and Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger. The Supreme Court is now
an enemy. Judges that lower courts are enemies,
county commissioners and vote counters. The
Republican Party itself has become an enemy to
some degree. And here's just like a little bit of
insight into how deep these delusional conspiracy
theories go. Fox News is now being pulled into a
prominent Trump cultist. And my pillow salesman,
Mike Lyndell, came up with this one at this
weekend's million Magga March, which fell a
little short of a million Magga people showing
up. And the claim is that Fox News is not just
coincidentally bad because they acknowledge Trump
lost. The claim is Fox News is part of a plot
along with, I guess, the left and voters
to overthrow Donald Trump. Listen to this
one. Here is Mike Lyndell laying it out.
Thank God. Why do you think Fox declared
Arizona with only 14 percent of the vote in? They
already know what they did. They were in on it.
You know, I'm serious. They had to
be in I you don't know this stuff.
I mean, all this stuff in. And you know what?
It's not just it's not just the ones behind
this that are going to end up, you know, being
a big piece of it. And they should all go to
prison when they are found out. And but how about
the Republicans out there, all of this stuff?
That's a technical term. I guess Fox News was in
on all of this stuff, says Michael Mandel. But
there it is. Fox News should go to prison when
it's all said and done, he says it's genuinely
hilarious that now there is a big criticism of
Fox News from the right, but for completely the
wrong reasons. Fox News is sort of like Rand Paul.
Broken clocks eventually will get to something.
That's right. And in this case, it's that the
daytime Fox News people are saying Trump lost, but
now suddenly the right is going nuts. And turning
on Fox News, he generally, Michael Andell, seems
generally disconnected from reality. He also says
that the Supreme Court will vote nine to nothing
on something and give the election to Trump.
It's going to happen is it's going to be it's
so blatant, everyone. I'm going to come
out in front and I'm going to call my foot
that there was no fraud. All nine of those Supreme
Court justices are going to vote nine zero because
you're sure it gets out of hand or a foot and
they're going to go insane. And there was massive
fraud of epic proportions. And and and then it's
going to unite our country. It's going to unite
our country. And when this comes out years from
now, when we're going to look back on this day,
we're going to say, wow, God in his hands
and all this. And this had to happen
in order to make a future brighter for every
single person in the United States and the world.
Now, that's not just some random guy, Michael
Lyndell of my pillow fame. Trump actually had
him at the White House a few months ago as part
of a coronavirus briefing. And he actually spoke
and said Trump is a blessing from God, a gift
from God of some kind. On the previous day,
he said, we are now in the end times, which is
usually a pretty big red flag. In my experience.
If someone starts talking about the end times
as something that explains day to day events,
you're dealing with a full blown lunatic. And
that's what Mike Lyndell seems to be. Take a look.
And then all of you, I want to thank every
one of you for coming out to support.
This isn't our prayer. This is support. Support.
The world is watching elections that have to
be fair in the country and the world because
otherwise it's end times, which we're probably
already in anyway. But that's a good thing
that Jesus loves you all. God bless you.
This is really a guy that I wouldn't even trust
about pillows, and he's a pillow salesman,
never mind about politics, another completely
out of this world moment was when another speaker
actually promoted pillows sold by Michael
Mandel. I guess because my pillow is one of
the very few sponsors of this event, it
just is just unbelievable. Take a look.
Give me a handclap.
And a special thank you
to the co-sponsor that really helped fund a lot
of this, Mr. My Pillow himself, Mike Lyndell.
Amazing patriot, loves his country, loves us,
loves the president and the president loves him,
and I got to tell you, I love his codes,
right? I love his pillows. I love his sheets.
I love his mattress topper.
And I love his coat because
you know what? The cracking has been
released. You are part of the cracken.
So for the best deals to support this patriot,
use the code cracking at my pillow dot com.
We've got to show him some love.
He doesn't talk about a lot of the hill
that he goes through behind the scenes friends
that I mean, listen, guys, that coupon code,
I have to admit, that's an even crazier coupon
code than anything I've I've offered. I actually
did not watch any of this million Magga thing over
the weekend. I sort of checked out of politics
over the weekend, and I still found myself
thinking about Mike Lyndell. Not something
I recommend people do, but I'm in the market
for a new pillow. Now, buy in the market. I'm
not it's not I'm not really in the market. I know
exactly what pillow I want to get. I want to get
another pillow just like the one I have. And
as I was making a mental note to pull off the
pillow case and check what kind of a pillow I
have, I thought to myself, imagine if I went
and bought one of those my pillow pillows. I then
immediately put it out of my mind and ordered the
exact same pillow. I already have moved on with my
day and then was presented last night, confronted
last night with videos of Michael and Dell saying
the Supreme Court will vote nine nothing and give
this election to Trump. Not going to happen.
But what might happen is Michael Andell runs
for governor, I think was it Minnesota
that he's thinking of running in
bizarre guy and the type of seedy character that
gets front and center placement from the current
administration. But the big story here is all of
these enemies cropping up within the Republican
Party and Trump cultists. And I want to have
sort of a bigger discussion about that next.